he had been campaigning as the candidate
of integrity but for many voters here in
Paris these past few days have tarnished
fossil fuels image will give you a week
I spell quake I was going to vote for
him because I thought he was clean but
now we are talking about a lot of money
and there will always be a dart about
his honesty roller dude what we don't
[ __ ] French politicians have so much
power and they behave like our ancestors
like Royals this really shows that young
the French Revolution we killed the
Royals but we didn't put an end to their
privileges all really privileged it's so
sad to hear about all these scandals
politicians are taking the moral high
ground and yet they are the worst
bandits We the People we have to tighten
our belts newspaper reports are
suggesting the former prime minister
paid almost 1 million euros in public
money to his wife and children for
fictional work a preliminary
investigation has been opened so far
without in dieting fee on directly but
the candidate in eyes the allegations
and goes on campaigning most of his
fellow Republicans are backing him how
is it that this is coming up now I do
believe that there is a plot somewhere
this investigation of the Justice is in
fact a political approach what would
happen if Francois Fiona did withdraw
his bid I think that the Congress of the
party will choose somebody because we
cannot go once more to primary election
so I think it will be an agreement
between you know a few candidates and we
will designate certainly by vote of
course the new candidate but we are not
at this stage yet but behind the scenes
Republican voices asking for his
replacement are getting stronger and
other presidential contenders like
marine lepen and Amano a macaw are
hoping that this will work to their
advantage with new scandals breaking
almost every day the pressure is growing
even if the legal challenge were to
disappear it seems that trust in film
has been
lost for good